if the aerial folks couldn't figure it
out who had the backing of one of the
smartest guys with a team that was an
incredibly sharp and well-organized and
build a great product who are we and in
a few weird and parallel used to be in
the 90s or 80s there were lots of
technology companies in cable television
today there's Grandal son of 0 there is
a reason because there is not a single
investor on either coast that'll put a
single dollar up to fund the company
because they know the company will die
because the guys on the other side will
figure out a way to kill it because
they're not interested in progress
they're interested in control but yet if
you win is it going to be as
transformational to television I don't
think so i think that these things take
a lot longer i think there will be no
change except for the people that don't
have access to decent signal and want to
use area and there are lots of them will
continue to have access to that i think
all the hyperbole we hear that the
world's going to end and the NFL is
going to leave well how does that sit
with the fact that 60 million people use
an antenna so what a few more million
will and that's really going to change
the world how will that end when the
fact is the cable companies are bound by
retransmission consent as a fact because
they are cable companies they're MVPDs
it doesn't matter what technology they
use you can exist you can exist with
cable operators you can exist with
broadcast napkin are people that you are
not a threat is what you're saying we're
not and I think we had a big benefit
broadcasters because we bring more
audience in 25 year olds I'm not signing
up for cable TV in New York City and
watching The Today Show The Time Warner
Cable they use area to do it what have
you not been able to do because you're
occupied with this what have you not
been able to Oh a lot I mean I think
we've been very slow in our growth
because we've been cautious about it's
an infrastructure company requires a lot
of capital so it's been a measured
amount of capital deployment to make
sure that you're being judicious despite
your confidence but you still been able
to raid one hundred million dollars oh
this is an infrastructure company this
is we're going to invest a lot more than
that and right now it's been sort of the
ground laying the groundwork but we want
to put out 50 markets and we want to
start marketing the product we want to
add more devices and we want to do a lot
of things so we haven't done because the
overshadowing it's 50 markets your goal
or where you want to be in the next year
and that's it or what more I think
what's your grand plan environment if
you if anybody knows me i have no grand
plans i'm one of those people that I
sort of generally know where i want to
go